so uh hello and welcome to the kickoff
workshop for
for fodzy the foundations of data
science uh institute
my name is peter bartlett i'm the
director of fotzy and piotr and i are
going to give an overview of the
institute
pierre is the co-director and we're very
excited about this collaboration
um disappointed of course that we can't
be hosting this workshop in in
in person
so we're we're confident it'll be a
great workshop this
celebration of the launch of fodzy
there's a really exciting lineup of
talks let me start by acknowledging the
role of the simon's institute fodzie at
berkeley's really
uh intertwined with the simon's
institute
and all of the public activities at
berkeley being organized through simon
so that's hugely important for us
big thank you to jesse gill who's done
all the organization for this workshop
jesse if you want to hey here he is
thanks a lot so let me start with
a little bit of the rationale behind
fonzie
so first of all
i better share my screen
how's that looking okay
so um
i guess first of all why why now why is
why is now the right time for
uh an institute for the foundations of
data science
um well data science has certainly
become the central science for the 21st
century
but of course people have been thinking
about the foundations
of data science for for more than 100
years
in the first half of the 20th century
intellectual giants were struggling with
how to rigorously
formulate some of the central concepts
in in data science
uh ideas like algorithms and probability
and inference and
uncertainty and so on um and and those
successes led to whole new
academic disciplines like computer
science and mathematical statistics
which separately focused on different
aspects of the processes of going from
data to decisions and now as
data science has become ubiquitous
across society
um those strands are coming back
together and and they're all important
in developing the foundations
so it's crucial to consider you know all
of these separate issues
uh together so specifying inferential
goals
developing models uh for the process
that generates the data
designing efficient algorithms
quantifying uncertainty
understanding the impacts of
misspecifications
the impacts of malevolent actions
understanding the effects of
interactions between a decision maker
and its environment
and understanding of course all the
social and ethical implications of
automated decision systems
so we need to draw on the the full range
of of classical
academic disciplines and it's important
to engage with the communities involved
in the wide range of applications of
data science in science and technology
and communist
so we set the right priorities for our
foundational research
so that's the thinking that went into
the vision for
an institute of this scale and what it
needs to address
we see ourselves as bringing together a
community to
lay the theoretical foundations of data
science and to do that we have to focus
on this full range of
of issues modeling issues inferential
issues
computational issues and societal issues
we we see the importance of emphasizing
of
the full variety of interactions between
a decision maker and its environment
so not just the classical view of a
batch of data or
a data stream but situations with
feedback
or sequential decision problems where
decisions at one time are going to
affect
later outcomes situations where we need
to
produce system to experiment to
understand causal relationships
situations where we need to be strategic
because there are other agents present
that have their own goals
we need to draw on multiple disciplines
bring all these disciplines back
together and and we need people with
expertise across disciplinary boundaries
we want to be sure as i mentioned that
our
foundational research is focused on the
most important directions
and we need to rethink data science
education and
human resource development to produce
a diverse cohort of future data science
leaders
and we want to create a national
resource to serve the broader data
science
foundational research community so
that's what fodzy is about building a
transdisciplinary research community
in the foundations of data science so
there's been a long history
of bridging these data science
disciplines at the various participating
institutions
here at berkeley we've had close ties
between statistics and ecs over the last
25 years with lots of joint appointments
across listed graduate classes and
all sorts of things like that close
cooperation between those two
departments
mit's research lab structures long
emphasized
transdisciplinary research so involving
faculty from cs and math in sea sale for
instance and econ and stat in lids and
more recently this um statistics and
data science center
and um recently uh in in both of those
institutions they've been
major institutional changes in the in
the data science direction
so berkeley created cdss uh led by
jennifer chase who's part of this
institute
and mit created the college of computing
which includes
the parallel entities um uh
in computer science and statistics and
in
data science in society
so this institute came out of two
nsf-funded centers at berkeley and at
mit
at berkeley the foundations of data
analysis institute foda led by uh
michael mahoney was the
the seed for the considerably expanded
uh fodzy team that's illustrated
um on this colorful colorful wheel here
the colors represent
the five different disciplines of
mathematics statistics theoretical
computer science
electrical engineering and economics um
foda had some great outcomes in terms of
research advances
a postdoc model that's emphasized
collaborations
and and a model that we're aiming to to
scale up in in fodzy and i'm
going to say a little bit about more
about that later piotr will also
um a simon's institute program on the
foundations of data science
um the the photo institute also
witnessed the development and
and scaling up of berkeley's pioneering
undergraduate data science curriculum
um so lots of exciting things came out
of came out of that
um uh tripods
uh nsf funded through the tripods
program
institute at berkeley this is the fodzy
team in the boston area which
which grew out of my fonts the mit
institute for foundations of data
science
and and that's also seen some some great
outcomes in research i i guess i should
say we're going to hear about
some of the fodzy research themes um
that came out of these earlier
institutes on on things like
um you know optimization meat sampling
on sublinear algorithms on machine
learning for algorithms on
causal inference so we will hear a bunch
about about those
those things later on so um
myfods also organized a series of
thematic workshops that were
a big success they organized an overlay
seminar series and and there were a
couple of new graduate programs launched
in data science areas
so as well as the mit group uh the fonzi
team in the boston area includes
senior personnel from boston university
from
harvard and northeastern who are heavily
involved in those
myford's activities um
and then uh the a big thank you i guess
to the nsf for funding fodzy through its
phase two tripods program
tripods is a great acronym
transdisciplinary research in
principles of data science um uh
and nsf awarded us twelve and a half
million dollars over over five years
um and and that's what um really
triggered bringing these two teams
together that's supporting foxy
um we brought these five institutions
that i mentioned together plus
uh there's uh also uh chun mei liu from
howard university and deepak kumar from
bryn mawr college whose
pictures are in this pinwheel somewhere
um and they're bringing expertise in
data science education and
they're going to help in broadening
participation in our activities
all right and we have a a set of
industrial partners also
verizon media google research microsoft
research
amazon and and linkedin plus scientific
partners at mit and
berkeley and and we're looking forward
to these collaborators helping us
for instance by getting involved in the
application domain segments that we're
planning for
for our workshops we're also looking
forward to uh a stream of
institute uh personnel uh interacting
with our partners through the the
postdoc mentoring program
um uh we'll say a little about that it's
the idea there is to have subsequent
positions at an industrial partner as
one option
uh and through things like summer
internships for grad students
so i mentioned at the start the big role
of the simon's institute so
um uh you know as i say that's that's uh
hugely important for us and for our
activities
okay so um uh
that's that's what fodzy's aiming to do
to lay the theoretical foundations for
the field of data science
uh to serve as a national resource a
nexus for research and education in data
science by hosting
public activities like research
workshops and summer schools
um to educate and mentor future leaders
in data science to broaden participation
and
enhance diversity in the data science
workforce uh
to engage with industrial and scientific
partners so that
so that our research is grounded in real
problems
um that's what we're about uh piotr
is going to tell us now about the
research themes and activities so i'll
hand over to
i'll hand over to him
you're on mute piotr
you are still muted
i can what about now yes we can hear you
yes all right and uh
that should do it okay so thanks again
peter
uh so in the next few slides uh i will
uh outline our plans how to
uh implement the fatsy mission
so i will start from uh the foundational
topics that we are planning to pursue
and uh on a high level our proposal
covers
eight themes that we believe can have
significant impact over the next five
years which is the duration of the fosse
and now each of these themes lies at the
intersection of at least two
and are often all three tripos
disciplines are the statistics
mathematics and the typical computer
science
on the high level our themes can be
classified into
two categories the first category which
is depicted here
studies various forms of interactions
between decision makers and their
environment so in particular will study
economics and learning
namely uh strategic interactions as i
studied in economics
and here will investigate situations
where strategic agents
interact with the other agents that use
machine learning or statistical
inference
and will develop theories that combine
the two perspectives
we also study our networks and graphical
models
which model pairwise and more general
combinatorial interactions
and that in this theme i will study
models for example graphones
as well as algorithms for those models
and their
limitations uh we'll also study
experimental interactions
where agents interact with the world are
trying to discover and validate what if
causal inferences
and uh this topic is of crucial
importance in healthcare for example
when trying to understand the treatment
efficacy
and we also study sequential
interactions with feedback
in the form of reinforcement learning
and the sequential design
and that this area has exploded in a
popularity over the last few years
but that's still not fully understood
theoretically
so these perspectives provide the
complementary viewpoints through which
we aim to
understand how intelligent agents can
interact with the
outside world and we believe that these
topics are of uh crucial
importance because our systems based on
machine learning and circuit inference
are now deployed in many real-world
scenarios
and are therefore it's important to
study them in that context as opposed to
just in isolation
and also there are natural connections
between these themes right for example
reinforcement learning is naturally
connected to causality causality with
graphical models and so on right so
we'll investigate those
connections as well now the second
category
covers the four key foundational themes
and uh specifically will study the
following will study a sampling
optimization
through geometric lens especially using
uh optimal transport theory
data processing at scale which covers
developing algorithms with a space
time communication or semi-complex this
small a sub in our in
the data size and here we'll study
topics such as
clustering numerical in algebra statical
estimation and
other problems the third topic is
accommodation complexity of classic and
statistical problems like estimation
robustness tolerance and so on and here
we'll investigate not only algorithms
but also theories that are enabled to
show
computational limitations on those
questions and again there has been
plenty of activity in this field over
the last few years
but that the overarching complexity
theory for statical questions is they're
still
to be developed and then finally i will
uh also study how to design algorithms
that use machine learning and
statistical inference
in order to improve their performance
this is also a very
uh recent popular area whose typical
foundations are still lacking
now for each of the themes we have
identified
the team broad objectives example
questions that we'll pursue
as well as the set of industrial or
scientific partners that will keep us
help us keep our activities connected to
applications
now i will not cover uh all of these
themes in detail because uh that's the
focus of
the next few hours okay so but you'll
see the slides are returning
uh in the talks later on uh instead
let me move on uh to describe the
activities uh through which we plan to
actually
accomplish uh all of uh all of this
and the basic idea of this project is
that uh the research will
revolve around those themes and uh we'll
work on all these themes in parallel
after the duration of the project
however
each team will be given an extra push
during specific semesters
during which we'll organize various
activities to further stimulate our
research
on those topics and the specific
activities that we envisioned are
as follows so first of all we'll
organize the workshops quite a few
workshops at least three workshops per
year sometimes more
each workshop will be dedicated to one
of the themes that
i mentioned earlier a segment of
those workshops will be structured as a
special semester the simon's institute
which will also include the boot camp
and other activities
additional idea of the workshop is that
they will cover
recent state-of-the-art developments as
well as talks on connections to
domain areas which are facilitated by
our industrial
and their scientific patterns now the
workshops
will be complemented with an annual
summer school
uh covering foundations of data science
and unlike workshops
which will change from semester to
semester
we envision that the material in summer
schools to be relatively stable
the idea is to cover foundations of our
data science that
any advanced undergrad or grad students
needs to know
in order to start research in this area
automatically we plan to
turn the material developing those
schools into a course modules
now all of these activities
involve in person interactions and you
know clearly it's
not happening during the pandemic so
because of that we'll need to make some
adjustments
that i can describe at the end during
the question parts
in addition we'll have a few activities
that are entirely virtual
so in particular will expand the overlay
seminar to all five uh
participating institutions uh so overly
seminar was uh initiative uh started at
uh mifolds
in phase one um the triforce project and
here
uh the idea is that during each semester
we select and record talks relevance to
the current theme and uh post them
on the dedicated youtube channel and we
already added a few such talks over the
last few weeks and
uh we'll keep adding them as more talks
arrive
and furthermore in order to maintain the
rhythm of collaboration
uh we will organize our weekly webinars
the talks will be typically given by
fatsy members but i will also have
occasional invited speakers as well i
should emphasize that
the vast majority of these activities
will be public with outcomes
posted and online and accessible tool
and in addition we also have a couple of
housekeeping events
again you know these are uh planned to
be in person events uh which are
you know mostly not be happening the
pandemic so we
will mostly have to wait until covet
is over
now in terms of human resources
development
our activities will involve postdocs our
grad students and the undergrads
for postdocs i will have a yearly
application process
with a single application but multiple
options are tailored to
preferred career paths of the applicants
and the options are as follows
at the first option sometimes we call
the oneplus one
uh so here the postdocs spent one year
at a one university and then moves to
another for the second year so this is a
tailor to postdocs who are mobile and
these postdocs will also become conduits
for collaborations between two
institutions
the second option you know is a home
base
here a postdoc mostly stays at the
single institution but
uses workshops and the other events to
visit other places to start
collaborations and
continue online later and the final
option is a
oneplus other so here the postdoc spends
one year at
one of the universities and then
continue in one of the participating
industrial partners and this is tailored
to more application-minded applicants
who envision carriers
for example in industrial research labs
and we have a
call for a postdocs which are peter will
mentioned
at the end so we are already hiring uh
starting from right now
and i should mention in addition to
postdocs
we'll have various plans for
students both the graduate students and
other grads
students will collaborate with apis
postdocs and visitors and will be
involved in a
mentoring and research collaboration
now in order to
broaden participation i will have uh
initiatives on a multiple level of the
whole pipeline
ranging from high school students to
postdocs
at the high school level i will create
and disseminate data science modules for
apcs principles high school calls which
is a berkeley's
flagship diversity outreach effort and
that this effort will be
led by george hack who developed
intercourses to data science at berkeley
at an undergraduate level one of our
summer schools will be organized in a
brilliant mall
so we hope that this will stimulate
interest in our foundation of data
science among the students
in there and furthermore will leverage
our collaboration with bryn moore and
the hawa to select and
recruit uh students from those schools
to attend other
footsie events and i will also have a
few initiatives to increase the
increased attendance of our women and
minorities at the
foxy events and data science event in
general
so uh finally we have several
initiatives of education
uh i covered uh most of them earlier one
that i was not covered
is a focus on the undergraduate level
where will further develop
undergrad data science courses so for
example will further develop the s102
which is a foundation of data science
course whose topics are close related to
interactions between
decision maker and the environment which
is also one of the
main themes of our project
and i will hand it back to
peter
great thanks piotr so
uh let me let me i guess give a couple
of highlights about how fonzie's managed
so we have a steering committee
um as well as pierre me there's uh mike
jordan
ronnie rubenfeld philippe rigolet and uh
ben you
uh actually they're all speaking today
on um the research themes that they're
they're also leading so this group meets
monthly
and and has strategic oversight of all
the the activities of the institute a
big thank you to the steering committee
members for all their efforts
um we also have an external advisory
board
uh with distinguished representatives of
the various disciplines from
from around the world uh and the plan
is for this board to meet every six
months to review how fodzy's progressing
to
advise on the prioritization of our
scientific activities
um you mentioned earlier you know we'd
like to see fonzie emerge
as a national resource an institute that
sets up the infrastructure to bring
together a transdisciplinary research
community to
lay the foundations of data science
piotr told us about
a lot of those planned activities
that'll benefit the broader research
community
things like workshops summer schools
collaborative research programs and so
on
um it's worth highlighting the scale of
of this aspect and and the level of
outside involvement
so uh you know we anticipate producing
videos from something like 500 hours of
high quality talks throughout the
throughout the period of the institute
involving
something of the order of uh you know
1500 researchers in
in our activities over that five years
so it's really substantial so
you know we'd like to see fodzy as much
more than just the
currently 47 researchers at these seven
universities and
and their groups um and you know of
course the exciting research that it
allows us to do
and the diverse cohort of future
research leaders we're hoping to train
these are all
great but we're also hoping to play a
part in in mobilizing a bigger research
community across this range of
disciplines
you know with this kind of grand goal of
redefining the foundations of data
science
so we're really hoping to see the
broader research community get involved
in our activities
you know if you have ideas about that or
questions we'd
uh really love to chat okay and
um uh we also wanted to say
you know i guess like i'm going to use
this soapbox to flag that we we're
looking for postdocs as uh
as piotr said these positions are across
a range of locations with opportunities
for working with
multiple mentors um on on the topics
that you're going to hear about in the
in the schedule today so feel free to
get in contact with us about these
there's you know this website fodzy.us
it's a work in progress there'll be
details posted there about
about the ad sometime later today so
if it's not already there please do
please do go back and look
um and we're looking forward to the rest
of the program um
you know which is really focused on the
science uh um
uh that that was the spiel from now on
it's the it's the
um the research part of things we've got
a bunch of talks by
uh research theme leaders across the
eight
fonzi research themes um
uh and let me stop sharing we
we have time for questions if if anybody
has
questions before we go to a break and
the break is you know in
in tune with the theme of getting
getting people collaborating we have
a 30 minute break uh
now that's i'm gonna be on gather town
so those
details of of gathertown will be um
there you go the link is in the chat
before we go to that
um if you do have questions uh
you're welcome to post those in the in
the q a
or if you're uh in this set of
panelists you can just speak up
and if not um uh we can go
we can go chat in uh in gather town
so if you just go into the into the chat
there there's a link
and um we'll call you back from in there
this
will this will actually be open for for
the rest of the day today uh if you want
to
um hang out with people there um
um but we'll be you know announcing the
starts of talks oh
we do have a question are today's talks
being recorded and will they be
available later
so thanks and so yes they will be
available later
um actually they're
being live streamed on youtube
so you know you can
you can also watch there and they'll be
available on youtube
essentially from when they're finished
all right
so uh we'll see you in gather time
did you have something to add no i would
think it you know
maybe we can wait like 30 seconds just
in case somebody
has any questions sure i think
uh going once going twice
okay i i don't think there are any
questions so we can just uh go gather
that's good